Are you still stuck just knitting squares
and rectangles on your knitting machine?
Let's change that.
Short row shaping, also called
partial knitting, is a game changer.
It lets you add curves,
angles and real shape to your knitting.
Think shoulder slopes, bust darts,
even sock toes and heels.
Have you ever wondered how to knit beyond
just plain old rectangles and squares?
Let me show you how short rows can open up
a whole new world
for your knitting machine.
Let's get started.
Hi, I'm Sue.
I'm the voice and the hands
behind the Knit it now videos.
Short row shaping or partial knitting
is exactly what it sounds like.
We knit part of a row instead of the full
width on the knitting machine.
We do this by putting some needles
in hold while continuing to knit others.
This creates wedges or angles
in the fabric perfect for shaping
garments and adding dimension.
It's one of those skills that really
levels up your knitting and helps you go
from flat, square pieces to more tailored,
fitted and artistic designs.
Let's take a quick look at how
this works on the knitting machine.
Instead of knitting all the way across
a row, you'll stop short of the full width
by placing some needles in hold
and then you'll continue knitting.
Each row covers fewer or more stitches,
depending on the shape
that you're creating.
Notice that there were more rows knit
on the right side and that side
is longer than the left.
The key is to prevent holes or gaps
where the short rows start and stop.
You can wrap a needle before moving on.
Sometimes you want to skip
that wrap and embrace the holes.
Making eyelets
Depending on the yarn or the design
that you're trying to knit,
the most important thing is to understand
how to plan your short
row shaping in advance.
So where do we actually use short rows?
Here are just a few examples.
Shoulder slopes for smooth Shoulder seams.
Bust darts to create better fitting
Sweaters no matter what your size.
Necklines shaping for round or scoop necks
without stair Steps to make
easier finishing Curved hems.
A beautiful way to add drape or
design interest to a garments.
Sock, heels and toes.
Now this is a classic short row use
and knitting circles.
Yeah, you can knit circles
on your machine with short rows.
Short rows are everywhere once
you start looking for them.
Keeping track of your pattern and your
needle counts and wrapping
are key to success.
Plus practice, practice, practice.
Even simple shapes like triangles or
wedges are a great way to practice
and build your confidence fast.
The Knit it now short row classroom has
lots of examples and a couple of skill
builders to help you get practice
and build your confidence.
With knitting short rows.
Short row shaping may be a little
intimidating at first,
but once you get the hang of it,
it opens up a whole new world
of possibilities on your knitting machine.
If you want more practice or patterns
that use short rows, be sure to check
out the resources at Knit It Now.
And if you have any questions or short
row success stories, leave a comment.
I'd love to hear from you.
Thanks for watching and happy knitting.